Batman will always definitely be the
hero we deserve but after headlining 10
films in the past three decades he's not
the hero we need right now let's take a
look at all the other Batman characters
who deserve their own movies if you want
a villain who's begging for a solo movie
clayface's origin story is basically
already the plot to an amazing horror
film the original version is set around
the filming of a slasher movie called
Dredd Castle but whenever it's time to
film a death scene suddenly the lights
go out and the actor playing the victim
mysteriously dies for real those who
catch glimpses of the fleeing killer see
that he looks like Clayface a famous
fictional monster from another old
horror film eventually Batman intervenes
and discovers that the Clayface Killer
is actually a horror actor makeup artist
vassal Carlo who played both the movie
monster Clayface and the killer in the
original Dredd Castle Carlo claims he
committed the murders because he didn't
want anyone replacing him as Dredd
castles killer he apparently played so
many fictional monsters that it turned
him into a real-life horror movie
villain a version of this story with or
without Batman could be an awesome
horror flick like scream 7 the 40's and
since he can look like anyone there's no
guarantee that they got the right guy
how's that for a third act twist usually
the only Batman villains who make it to
the big screen are the truly threatening
a list masterminds like the Joker and
Ra's al Ghul that's all well and good
but a wonderful thing about Batman is
that he has so many villains that go
beyond just the household names Gotham
has an extremely deep roster of b-list
baddies so we'd be remiss if we didn't
include at least one of Batman's miner
more comedic enemies ok are you making
some of those up nope they're all real
somewhere far down towards the bottom of
the roster you'll find an obscure Batman
villain known as the eraser his real
name is Lenny Fiasco and he's our pick
for a point of view character in the
world of Batman's many Forgotten foes
the eraser has found an interesting
niche in Gotham's criminal underworld
and that he works as a fixer for other
villains helping them erase the evidence
of their crimes in exchange for a 20
percent cut
a film centered on the eraser could be a
low-stakes crime comedy along the lines
of The Big Lebowski whenever another
Batman villain Boches one of their
supervillain plots the eraser ash I put
upon everyman dons his giant pencil
costume and does his best to clean
things up how great would it be to see
the working-class side of super villainy
with cameo appearances from the
different Batman villains who need to
call upon the eraser services we've had
many different actors play Batman over
the years but every cinematic version of
Batman has been Bruce Wayne underneath
the cape and cowl the 2009 comic by
Grant Morrison and Frank Quitely simply
entitled Batman and Robin however could
be adapted pretty much directly into an
excellent film about someone trying to
fill Bruce Wayne's big black boots when
the story opens Bruce Wayne has been
killed by Darkseid and Dick Grayson the
first Robin who had more recently been
the hero Nightwing decides to take over
the role of the Dark Knight to keep
things safe in Gotham City he also takes
on Damian Wayne Bruce's son with Talia
al Ghul as his Robin because Damian was
raised by an order of assassins without
ever knowing his father he grew up
rebellious arrogant and violent and he
has no respect for dick as his partner
needless to say dick and Damian's first
few missions didn't go particularly well
at one point dick tells Alfred that he
feels like a kid doing a Batman voice
and that it was foolish to even try to
replace Bruce Wayne after Alfred
encourages him to treat the identity of
Batman as a performance in which he's
playing a role dick stops trying to be
Bruce Wayne and he learns to be Batman
in his own way and after Damian's
recklessness almost gets him killed and
dick asked to save him he starts to
realize that maybe this new Batman
actually knows what he's doing
perhaps no single Batman character has
had a wider array of comic-book
portrayals than Pamela Isley better
known to Gotham City by her highly
evocative plant-based criminal code name
poisoned poison ivy
she's been everything from a thief to an
eco-terrorist to a superhero in her own
right with powers that range from being
a nearly normal human with an immunity
to toxins and a serious knack for
gardening to a living avatar of plant
life itself who can take over the entire
world with hypnotic spores it might seem
like that inconsistency could hurt her
as a character but really it just means
that there are a lot of different
options when it comes to bringing her to
film including putting them all together
in one it would be easy enough to tell a
story that followed the example of a
movie like Captain Marvel where Pamela's
control of her plant powers would slowly
ramp up over the course of the film
there's even an option to show her as
more than just a costumed criminal but
as a defender of a planet in dire need
of help against very relevant issues
like climate change she could even work
in the absence of Batman by pitting her
against bad guys like Jason Woodrum sure
they already did that in Batman and
Robin but it's not like anyone would
notice plus her romantic relationship
with Harley Quinn has made her a fan
favorite giving her a ready-made
connection to the current run of DC
movies one which Harley Quinn actress
Margot Robbie says she wants to explore
on screen there are a lot of origin
stories about bad guys who learn to be
good but what about one where a good guy
turns bad there are numerous versions of
mr. Freeze's origin story but typically
Victor fries who's actually a doctor not
a mister is a brilliant scientist whose
wife Nora contracts a terminal illness
freeze searches for a cure and in order
to buy himself some time to look he puts
her into cryonics stasis later an
accident in the cryonics lab alters
Victor's body chemistry leaving him
unable to live outside a sub-zero
environment
he turns to crime to fund his
increasingly expensive research not to
mention his presumably massive
air-conditioning bills so he makes a
freeze gun and starts stealing stuff
beneath all the wonderful campy nonsense
the tragedy of mr. freeze holds a
surprisingly touching message about love
and more
ality because of Victor's unwillingness
to accept his wife's impending death he
ends up squandering both their lives
trying in vain to change her destiny
when he should have just enjoyed what
time he and Nora had left together
fleeting though it might be or to put
another way
after a dire diagnosis a brilliant yet
cash-strapped scientists invents a
criminal alter-ego to help get money for
his family it's basically everything you
like about Breaking Bad except that
instead of making meth like Walter White
Victor fries invented a freeze gun and
started fighting Batman while making ice
puns Gotham central began in 2002 as a
comic book series with an interesting
hook it's a law-and-order style police
procedural set in Gotham City with an
ensemble cast focusing on the normal
people who try to keep law and order in
a city dominated by superheroes and
deadly costumed villains during its
forty issue run it was a critical
darling and features a number of stories
that could be adapted into an excellent
new our detective movie perhaps the most
famous story from Gotham central was
half a life in which two-face puts into
motion an elaborate plan to destroy the
life of Renee Montoya one of Gotham's
best detectives by hiring someone to
outer as a lesbian it then turns out
that this is just step one of his plan
giving Montoya a motive because later
two-face murders the person he hired and
frames Montoya for it Montoya ends up in
jail and the rest of her colleagues on
the GCPD need to catch two-face and
clear their colleagues name another way
to go would be a story like dead Robin
which is a fascinating look into how the
criminal justice system of Gotham
intersects with the world of superheroes
in this tale Gotham police find the dead
body of a teenage boy in a Robin costume
with no identification they're not sure
if he's the real Robin or just a kid
dressed up like him but they have to
attempt to identify the body and figure
out who killed him while navigating a
world of secret identities it's an
excellent hook for a murder mystery and
it only gets better from there
you think we'd have seen a Batgirl movie
by now Joss Whedon was writing one for a
while but has since left claiming he
didn't have a story currently Christina
Hudson
the writer of bumblebee is attached to a
potential film but potential is all it
has right now as the project still lacks
a director
maybe the reason it's taking so long is
because Barbara Gordon's history is more
than a little complicated here's the
quick version
she was Batgirl she got paralyzed by the
Joker so she became Oracle a super
hacker information broker for
superheroes some readers like this
because it was cool to see a disabled
superhero but some didn't because they
thought she never should have been
paralyzed in The Killing Joke to begin
with then Barbara's paralysis went away
and thanks to the universe being
rebooted she became Batgirl once more
and again some readers like this and
some didn't with all of that to deal
with how do you make a movie about
Batgirl you could make a dual timeline
story with some scenes taking place
during Barbara's days as Batgirl and
others during her time as Oracle then
again maybe it would be better to tell a
breezy continuity light story and not
mention the paralysis at all but that
would mean ignoring almost 30 years of
her history and some very important
representation it's a tough problem to
crack but if anyone deserves to have the
effort put in its Barbara Gordon if you
haven't heard a cat man we don't blame
you from his earliest appearance in the
1960s
he's been mostly just a punch line
between a costume that's goofy even by
Silver Age DC standards and his use of
Catering's cat man has the somewhat
unique distinction of being a fictional
character who's accused in universe of
being a ripoff of
other much cooler characters although he
languished in obscurity for decades cat
man came back in the mid 2000s in the
pages of secret six a sort of spiritual
successor to Suicide Squad but without
the part where they were working for the
good guys instead this was the story of
a type of super team that hasn't been
seen much in the movie so far
super mercenaries the secret six are
superhuman muscle for hire and as such
their morality is somewhat flexible
perhaps the six is most film worthy
Adventure occurs when they gain
possession of a mystical item known as a
get out of hell free card
the name implies it's a little metal
rectangle that allows its bearer to
rescue anyone's soul from hell and
return them to the world of the living
needless to say once it becomes widely
known that the secret six possesses this
every supervillain in the world starts
coming for them a film adaptation about
Cat Man and the rest of the six during
this time could be a madcap guardians of
the galaxy style dirty action comedy
with a heart of gold
sure cat man might be a dumb name but
come on is it any worse than star-lord
simply put Batman Beyond is one of the
greatest superhero cartoons of all time
it takes place in a futuristic cyberpunk
Gotham where Bruce Wayne is retired from
his life as Batman and now he's a bitter
jaded shuttin inner Terry McGinnis a
rebellious teenager with a good heart
who accidentally discovers the secret
identity of Batman when Terry's father
is then murdered Terry steals a bat suit
from Bruce Wayne and sets out to bring
his father's killer to justice
although Bruce tries to stop him at
first once he realizes that Terry is a
good kid with pure intentions he decides
to take Terry under his pointy cape and
serves as the guy in the chair doing
research and giving him advice there's
so much to love about the idea of a
Batman Beyond movie franchise the
cyberpunk setting would look gorgeous in
live-action and there's an entirely new
rogues gallery of creepy villains like
inked blight Spellbinder and more and
you know what Michael Keaton is just
about the right age nowadays to play a
retired Bruce Wayne just saying check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]